[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département à ces
parties a pour le sommaire à baseball et
qu'on gare de montigny le bretonneux
orohiti arracher une victoire sur les
deux matches qu'ils ont joués ce
week-end pour rouen l'une des meilleures
équipes du championnat de première
division
les réactions sont à suivre dans ce
magazine basket le moins de 13 ans de
l'équipe de maurepas vente en congé ce
samedi après midi leur neuvième victoire
de la saison en 9 matches disputés
c'était contre le chesnay versailles
résultat qui leur permet d'être champion
départemental et de jouer la finale
régionale pour l'ade le titre ile de
france plus de renseignements à suivre
gymnastique pour la deuxième année
consécutive la finale
interdépartementale des équipes
fédérales a et b étaient organisées tout
au long du week-end au gymnase pierre de
coubertin de montigny le bretonneux
coup de projecteur sur ce rendez vous
qui a réuni à 6 150 gymnastes on ouvre
maintenant une large page résultats
on commence tout de suite ce magazine
par du baseball dans le championnat de
première division les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux recevait ce
dimanche dans un stade jean maréchal une
des meilleures équipes de france rouen
l'occasion de la 5e journée et lézignan
montants ont fait mieux que tenir face
aux rouennais
après s'être inclinés 5 à 4 dans la
première partie les cougars l'ont
emporté 4 à 2 dans le second match
occasion pour le manager de l'équipe
rodolphe le meur de revenir sur les
objectifs du club
aucune équipe n est plus forte que
l'autre c'est ça se passe mentalement au
oui à et plus j'ai plusieurs fois
champion de france donc c'est clair
qu'ils ont l'habitude on veut dans les
trois premiers aller en play-offs faire
mieux que la demi finale donc aller en
finale et en général quand on arrive en
finale ça se gagne au final ça joue pas
on dit généralement ça se gagne avec
deux matches de retard montigny le
bretonneux est actuellement à la 4e
place du championnat trois victoires de
son adversaire du jour
rouen 2e du championnat on continue ce
magazine par un sport venus également de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique le football
américain les moins de 19 ans des
templiers d'elancourt jouer ce week-end
contre les cougars de
saint-ouen-l'aumône en quarts de finale
du championnat de france
les élans courtois longtemps porté 30 à
14 pour débriefer cette rencontre nous
avons le plaisir de recevoir sur ce
plateau l'entraîneur dominique
mozziconacci et deux joueurs et
capitaine de l'équipe et yanis paulin et
mathis ducrocq bonsoir bonsoir
alors qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
sur cette rencontre coach la différence
c'est le niveau 2 comment dire
d'entraînement qu'on leur impose tout
simplement et surtout la discipline
discipline la rigueur vous étiez aussi
ça cette rencontre bien dominé la
première mi temps malgré la chaleur et
on est revenu dans les vestiaires dans
une optique de toujours 0 à 0 donc
toujours concentré donc c'est la
première mi-temps vraiment qui a joué
sur cette rencontre vous mener largement
à la mi temps on dit j'ai bien vu avec
2000 et bien oui oui mais après à 2
mi-temps avec la chaleur on s'est un peu
relâché
du coup ils ont monté un peu con tout tu
peux mais on n'a pas lâché quoi tu vous
vous attendiez à une victoire aussi
large pas aussi large
mais moi je m'attendais quand même à une
victoire parce que
parce que vous étiez quand même contre
saint-ouen l'aumône qui était invaincu
qui était un temps songé en dollar ouais
c'est sûr mais ils nous avaient pas vous
étiez hyper serein avant la rencontre
j'étais sûr pas hyper mais j'étais
serein et comment vous avez fait pour
les motiver avant la rencontre bon alors
surtout face à une équipe aussi forte
ben on leur fait notre petit speech
habituel mais c'est surtout à eux entre
eux en fait au final c'est que on les a
tellement formaté que maintenant ils
sont capables de faire les choses même
si on capable dé ceux de se motiver
eux-mêmes et puis deux allez quoi vous
aviez très bien préparé ce match
du côté des joueurs on s'assure puisque
en dix ans est en playoff
donc c'est une autre optique c'est une
autre saison qui commence et c'est
vendre une autre saison qui commence et
on est vraiment tout le monde est à fond
dedans tout on est motivé on compte
viser le titre
donc sur les playoffs playoffs il n'y a
qu'un seul match à chaque fois oui c'est
c'est un avantage pour vous oui ça parle
être coach ça davantage
c'est un avantage et un inconvénient est
ce qu'un avantage oui parce que
on sait que à chaque match gagné c'est
une c on sait qu'on a réussi quelque
chose une concrétisation
par contre si on perd bas c'est fini
qu'on est en vacances et ça a été
comment la fin la rencontre c'était
vraiment une explosion de joie dans le
vestiaire où vous avez été plutôt
mesurée dans ses 10 ans finalement ce
n'était la fed cela fait un quart de
finale c'était la fête
ça l'était lescouffe les deux coups
pâtissier finale c'était une délivrance
en fait déjà par la chaleur et/ou puis
la pression qu'ils relâchent quoi donc
vraiment ça fait tout il faut que les
gens regardent un petit peu les pieds
sur terre après une rencontre comme
celle là où il faut rester terne export
mais on peut se dire forcément parce que
la saison n'est pas encore finie
du coup donc oui il faut garder les
pieds sur terre et est toujours continue
de travailler
mathis et son récent coéquiper voilà je
crois savoir que votre dieu s'appelle my
à sessègnon qui fait gagner à l'équipe
u19 pourquoi ce surnom c'est l'équipe
entière qui fait gagner l'équipe mais ça
date de notre premier match de play-offs
nous chez les mariners et ben c'est dû à
matisse pour ma et iguiniz pour y aille
à la coi c'est beaucoup dans la victoire
est vraiment important soit dû au 19
février
il fait beaucoup fait beaucoup mais
comme matisse à 10 et c'est l'équipe
entière
au final et c'est un duo également qu'il
doit performer sur la prochaine
rencontre parce que vous allez affronter
également au groupe poids lourds on a
fait contre les flash de la courneuve
qui gagne est déjà pas mal de titre en
juniors mai
comme j'ai dit nous ont pas encore
affronté vous avez une chance on a
toujours les on a toujours toujours les
chances qu'il faut une victoire pour
l'afrique voilà c'est ça merci à tous
les trois devaient passer sur ce plateau
on va évidemment sur avec attention ces
demi finales du championnat de france et
on espère que vous pourrez fêter votre
titre ici à sur ce plateau
merci beaucoup on poursuit à part du
basket les moins de 13 ans de l'équipe
de maurepas ont engrangé ce samedi après
midi au gymnase de la malle me donnent
leur neuvième victoire de la saison en 9
matches contre l'entente le
chesnay-versailles un score de 47 à 31
qui leur permet de valider leur place de
champion départemental des yvelines et
de jouer la finale régionale pour le
titre ile-de-france on écoute les
réactions micro de nicolas quere le miz
tout le monde était évidemment ravi de
cette performance
on est champion on est fiers on est tous
de nos entraînements c'est qu'elle y
travaille on a beaucoup couru
oui c'est un bon esprit d'équipé vous
cette année pas très content
on le savait ça va être une double
confrontation face à versailles et dont
les gamins agit de la plus belle des
manières en troisième quart-temps ils
reviennent à six points
et puis voilà on arrive à un point temps
mort mais en zéro et là on sent que
l'équipe adverse balle en prend un coup
sur la tête et on n'a plus qu'à gérer la
fin du match c'est génial pour les
gamins c'est génial après le football
américain le basket et le baseball un
mode au soccer dans cette émission dans
le championnat de régionale 4 tracks n'y
arrive toujours pas les trappistes se
sont inclinés 1 à 0 à domicile contre
l'équipe 2 du blanc-mesnil leur douzième
défaite de la saison sur 23 matches
joués au classement trappe rester
l'inquiétant 12e place sur 14 équipes
engagées et devra se battre jusqu'à la
dernière journée pour assurer à sa
survie football toujours mais cette fois
ci dans le championnat de première
division de district la lutte
s'intensifie en cette fin de saison ce
dimanche maurepas s'est imposé 4 buts à
2 contre les clayes-sous-bois reste à la
cinquième place du classement du en
cours gagne 1 0 sur la pelouse du leader
les mureaux le chesnay domine le pec 1 à
0 à hardricourt remporte son duel contre
epône de justesse 2 1
enfin à montigny le bretonneux a été
corrigé 4 à 0 sur son terrain par où ils
résultats qui devraient condamner
lésigny montagne descente en fin de
saison
un mot de ballon ovale maintenant le
rugby-club de versailles s'est
brillamment qualifiée ce dimanche pour
les seizièmes de finale du championnat
de france en venant à bout du rc roubaix
sur terrain neutre à bové les versions
maîtriser l'ensemble de la partie pour
l'emporter 37 à 12
les joueurs de la cité royale joueront
leur prochain match le 20 mai prochain
toujours sur terrain neutre contre un
adversaire qui reste encore à confirmer
on voit maintenant les ballons pour
parler à de gymnastique pour la deuxième
année consécutive la finale
interdépartementale des équipes
fédérales a et b étaient organisées tout
au long du week-end au gymnase pierre de
coubertin de montigny le bretonneux
laurent des voix réunit plus de 650
participants venus de quatre
départements franciliens des images de
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est l'une des compétitions les plus
attendus de l'année pour les clubs
locaux
la finale interdépartementale des
équipes fédérales étaient organisées à
montigny le bretonneux
avec à la clé une bonne dose de stress
avant le début des épreuves
au début c'est pas stressant mais dès
qu'on arrivait 20 11
est-ce mais après on
on s'y habitue c'est donc après sûr
qu'il faut être entraînés au programme
quatre agrès pour les 650 gymnastes âgés
de 10 à 19 ans les participants se sont
essayés au saut au sol à la barre et à
la poutre
c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut savoir
appréhender la peur et les choses comme
ça c'est vrai qu'il ya certains
mouvements qui sont plus compliquées qui
nous font peur et du coup il faut qu'on
apprenne à gérer notre stress mais quand
on doit faire des mouvements des sauts
des choses comme ça parfois ça fait un
peu peur d agréer qu'il a fallu dompter
pour impressionner les juges de la
compétition les gymnastes ont été notées
sur les codes du pointage décliner des
notations internationales
il y à une note d qui permet qui leur
donne des points en fonction des
éléments qu'elles ont produit et une
note
eux qui est de la note d'exécution qui
les pénalise sur toutes les petites
fautes ou les grosses route qu'elles ont
fait
les juges ont notamment été impressionné
par montigny le bretonneux le club
organisateur est reparti avec trois
médailles dont un titre en individuel du
golfe à présent et de la ryder cup
comme tous les lundis tv 68 vous propose
de découvrir les moments qui ont marqué
l'histoire de la compétition aujourd'hui
le dtn de la fédération française de
golf christophe muniesa vous présente
l'un de ses meilleurs souvenirs de la
compétition regarder
[Musique]
je me souviens la ryder cup de l'édition
de 99 qui s'est déroulée aux états unis
sur le parcours de brookline à côté de
boston
et c'est une ryder cup assez symbolique
pour les français puisque c'était la
première sélection d'un français en
ryder cup le grand jean van de velde
l'équipe européenne était plutôt dans
une bonne dynamique puisque elle avait
remporté quelques éditions précédents de
la ryder cup et le jeu était en train de
s'équilibrer entre les deux continents
l'europe et les états unis on le sait
que c'est qu'au début de la compétition
les etats unis se sont imposés de très
très nombreuses fois et c'était
difficile pour l'équipe européenne
d'être au niveau de l'équipe américaine
on attendait beaucoup de cette ryder cup
99 avec jean dans l'équipe et ça a
démarré de la meilleure des manières
puisque notamment dans les doubles on le
sait c'est une des forces de l'équipe
européenne d'être en capacité de prendre
quelques points d'avance sur les doubles
hélas c'est précisément le scénario qui
s'était produit puisque l'europe avec
quatre points d'avancé avant le
lancement des simples qui se déroule le
dimanche et alors que les européens
avaient quatre points d'avance à
l'entâme des simples petit à petit les
américains ont refait leur retard sur
l'équipe d'europe glanant des points les
uns après les autres et
le point de la victoire a été ramené par
les américains dans le match qui
opposait justin leenhardt à jose maria
olazabal et c'est un moment de golf à
ses célèbres pas pour de très bonnes
raisons d'ailleurs parce que lorsque
justin hainard va rentrer son pote sur
le green du 17
théoriquement olazabal avait encore la
possibilité de rentrer son pote pour
égaliser le match et que l'europe
conserve une chance mais devant la
ferveur populaire
l'équipe américaine les officiels de
l'équipe américaine ont envahi le green
avant même que la balle n'est à jouer
son pote et 7
olazabal a raté derrière et ce fait de
jeu a marqué d'une certaine manière
l'histoire de la ryder cup parce que
depuis les capitaines européen les
capitaines américain en référence à ce
moment pas très fair play ont invité
systématiquement leurs joueurs à faire
preuve justement du plus grand respect à
l'égard des joueurs adverses en toutes
circonstances et depuis il n'y a pas eu
d'incident de telle nature a déploré est
en tout cas on se souviendra de cette
victoire fantastique pour les américains
et sept défaites douloureuses pour les
européens à brookline
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tb
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]